[Music]
all right in get over it news just get
over it get over at David that real
leather peeve is a [ __ ] to me all the
time
- JK parties are those pants velvet oh
my god we're rolling wait who is this
this is real leather right when I'm like
three - submitted by Chelsea a a mail
carrier refusing to deliver packages
inside a florida nudist communities
facing criticism what slug he doesn't
want to see dick and balls I know I'm
with him I can't wait for a meteor to
just take us all out cuz this is
ridiculous oh it's a nudist colony do
you know is mostly senior citizens I'll
rather [ __ ] watch oh no I try to come
up with something clever didn't work out
we sorta halfway oh yeah I wouldn't mind
deliver toys candy hey I would not feel
comfortable you've never been to an
all-girl nudists like spa if something
no I I can't remember the last time I
saw somebody fully naked
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah oh yeah I know but running joke
that nobody's ever gonna bite the bullet
and marry me so like this yeah there's
no I don't say that yeah it's sad but um
yeah but see that's a difference girls
girls not having dick it's not because
they can't if women it's a choice yeah
guys don't have vagina it's not our
choice it's just not coming at us you
see that meme of the cat well and it's a
room full of nothing but [ __ ] hot
dogs like wieners it's like this is a
girl on the internet and it's [ __ ]
bunch of wieners
that's exactly whatever the cat's face
that's exactly what are you alive true
just being a girl girls are pinky girls
are picky because you guys have options
but I would not mind
delivery's have you ever been around
like a really attractive male and you
just see women come to him like a moth
to a flame yeah weird it's [ __ ] wet
and it pisses me off I don't understand
that [ __ ] no no I don't like attractive
dudes like you gotta be like a six or a
seven you like ugly guys cuz you trap
them ah no no it's not cuz I trap him
but it's because like I'm insecure
so like eight nines and tens like I
don't want to be worried every day that
somebody's gonna steal my man like I
want like a nice like six or seven yeah
and I remember like early early our
conversation days before Jay candies and
then all of you guys were like what that
makes no that's that's why I Drive a
Honda Element cuz I don't want anybody
just you know [ __ ] you know it's because
like I'm you know because I'm Tesla the
test is different though okay I saving
the earth see that the Honda Element
though it allows me to go to these like
ghetto taco shops without worrying about
my [ __ ] I mean you can't you know what I
have nothing to do with girls hole
that's all I was just making something
analogous like that's the reason why I
like my Honda Element because six or
seven to me yeah I'm saying like yeah so
you know at least six seven that's like
come on no no and then they were all say
like Oh what does it say well Casey I'm
like yeah what does that say about Casey
what does that say about case yeah
that's how I
tied to the wall that's not true because
you just said you only go for six or
seven so he was a suit he's beautiful to
meet you know there's this nudist
community in Florida and so they're st.
they're complaining about this
substitute mail carrier that she refuses
to deliver parcels to the community
because she's saying
apparently she's just very uncomfortable
with us dude what if she's trying to
deliver [ __ ] in the men are like do you
want think you would even be accepted in
the community anymore cuz it's from what
I read like the nudist community they're
just like really tight-knit really
family friendly there's stuff okay
they can't be open and friendly if she's
a substitute mail person which means
that she only had to deliver the mail
once and they freaked out like she could
just be approved to like who knows I
don't know I try to see no [ __ ] balls
dragging on me right like it's not my
[ __ ] pretty interesting
[ __ ] it saw my oh that's interesting
whoa curious but then again I have been
to a sauna like a cream soda might know
I had you Korean I the [ __ ] is home what
are you talking about say it all Korean
I went to a Korean sauna so maybe it
won't freak me out as much like if I
just knew that you know what I'm used to
naked people
imma give you a bonus that day you might
see a finance woman why not and that's
that I have to put her package over my
package so I just she doesn't see in the
passenger run away will just be worried
like imagine like you're dropping to
mail off and like it's the old lady and
she turns around too fast you get a
titty Oh Jen even think about that yeah
I'm too tall to worry about that [ __ ] I
don't know why
I feel like I'd be the one embarrassed
if they're naked and I'm not so to make
them funny
you're like delivering [ __ ] he's like oh
it's that time like a like a mailman but
it's like a Magic Mike mailman out mail
flights everyone's wearing those flesh
colored bikinis of the man like you know
what the fur and stuff not the fur berry
championship I'll just wear that sleeps
naked I do me know sometimes that
anymore though cuz I I feel weird
picking up Tiger when he's sleeping no
but yeah so they're meant to be here
that they have mailboxes outside of the
gate and so usually that's where they
leave the mail and if they receive a
package that's too big for the could
have fit my package into your slot
that's the cage you need that job you
were born for that job thank you
get the [ __ ] out of here dude all right
so I lost my job guys
yes I admit that's when they'll hand
deliver it to the actual home like where
people live and they they have FedEx and
UPS delivery guys on the regular basis
also and no one has ever had a problem
until this the [ __ ] substitute that's
why yeah her IP she's allowed to have
her opinions about nudity it's not
something culturally that she grew up
with so why not why why dog on her first
sure but these people were saying well
it's your job if he can't do your job
and yeah it wasn't it's not within her
thing but that's a little different too
though you know if it's her job to
deliver the package of it doesn't fit
and out in the mailboxes outside of the
gate if it's her job to do that instead
what she's doing is she's just saying
like
undeliverable and she won't even runs
away yeah because now you're balancing a
different line - so you're also talking
about something that people aren't
comfortable or uncomfortable with their
with their job you know what I mean
because we could say that for anything
well it's your job to be my assistant so
suck my dick you know I think - like
morality speaking - yeah I guess on the
job when they're hiring you're they're
not telling you hey you're gonna have to
deliver it or nerd is calling her maybe
she wasn't even you know I think a crack
house I'm not going into that exactly
we're like you know I mean like I'm not
going to that motel there's always
[ __ ] like crazy people there yeah
well I guess these residents they're
just upset too because they're saying
like there's certain there's some reddit
there are some residents that they're
they really need the packages because
sometimes it's medication and they can't
wait like another we they're probably
super mad too because like they feel
judged
like she won't deliver it because I'm
all the time how come she can't just ask
her ups or Atmel like USPS superiors
life can I not be on this route yeah
that should want to see no dick well the
spokeswoman for the USPS said that she
isn't doing anything wrong that carriers
are not required to deliver beyond the
centralized unit so that's what she's
saying oh how many is what is this like
I wouldn't be mad at them I just said
that yo can I just get a different
carrier if they're uncomfortable with
coming this way that's all that is yeah
people switch milk like that all the
time yeah big deal I do know one thing
though like so the ancient Greeks used
to do the Olympics naked things to work
out naked and all that so I tried to do
it it's not easy
wait well in the comfort of my home it
smells pretty public because your
windows are wide open and everyone's but
in the morning it's dark inside weirder
like burpies naked weight on your balls
like what you gonna do no I'm doing
bodyweight stuff huh you're doing
burpees naked yeah well burpees body
squats karate everything it's not
comfortable it's not easy I rather have
underwear or like an additional clap
it flops it does it flops and it's like
you're not used to it because you're
used to like some patty or something to
keep it snug right so I'm like how did
they how is this more comfortable why
would they do this before I don't know
they probably used to they're probably
showing off to like to compete with
other men to show like how silly
jackoff and get a boner before they
wrestle someone yeah and like look
directly into their eyes and finish Wow
oh because they were pretty good [ __ ]
was crazy yeah yeah yeah they'd look
into each other's eyes they were super
gay
but um ham but but I also heard that
little dicks were beautiful back then
all this fat you've got little dicks
yeah cuz it's more pleasant oh this
batch is huge but it's thick is like my
size Oh cute yeah yeah all the balls are
bigger than yeah actually and that's
funny because like that's that's like an
ideal paint like a night like everybody
appreciates a good set of balls you
don't want to dig that's too big oh
really
not a ball person oh my god I told you
they exist are you oh my god you don't
appreciate like a good set of ball what
is it what makes a good match my hair
like it's a good size and they're like
firm firm yeah like a but how do you
feel like when it gets really cold and
they turn into walnuts I would prefer
that act like walnut yeah you have one
other woman that liked balls and now
you're the other person and I was too
young at the time a to shy to ask her
why so why do you was so what do you
like about balls and is the preference
like if you know what I get scolded they
turn into like a shriveled up brain yes
I think you know honestly I think that
every woman just needs to meet a good
pair of balls and then they'll just
appreciate it for the rest of like
you'll spend the rest of your life
looking for like hair or no hair on
balls I don't care just this it's the
structure it's the structure II like
weight of it yeah
is it like a sack of like melons like a
like a sack that can stand on its own
it's like great you know there's your
wife right there everybody
that's so weird I guys already feel
self-conscious about their penis size
now Ron dude they got to worry about
their ball sack tuition I would [ __ ] you
but your balls kind of like this but
your balls yeah I think it's like you
know guys are there's like tits are tits
guys or girls
yo by the way she has a [ __ ] in a minute
so Bob garble batshit like scope oh my
god
[Music]